number seven taking on Papa Bear
okay stuff is white so three-strike you
start with white or white now this is
called the Danny gambit the Danny three
check gambit yeah where I go I go all-in
and I uh a new design you know I don't
reside I anticipate that that you don't
know how easily I'm going to be able to
deliver checks all right get ready get
ready for the noise man the noise is
gonna be Broughton yeah that's fine I
mean you're kind of dead lost about the
market dead lost then you see something
that I don't see I'll tell you that
which is okay that probably doesn't
shock the world right there but okay
what you're going to get a single check
now ask me if I could make like good
sweet chunks you know you're not going
to get a third check buddy
not happen not happening yeah okay
there's your check I'm glad you got it
you got your single check okay so you're
gonna are you going to sack your queen
for your next check the thing is as long
as my king of white square as long as
when is on the white square like where
you know what's the deal yeah this is a
dinner this is the deal all right oh man
that is oh man oh I see
okay everybody he's threatening rook
takes East six and Queen takes e8 mate
or a3 checkmate but if I Castle he plays
Queen takes h7 King takes and then
Knight g5 check so I'm in a bit of a
pickle all right we have to run the King
we're running the Bulls everybody mvl is
coming you know if I move the Queen he
he takes with check all right it's time
to sack the Queen we're all in we're all
in for our next check oh man you don't
even get the next check I don't even get
another check this is okay this is
ridiculous this isn't good so do you
have a theory that white is winning
every time or am I just that bad uh
whites advantage is quite big but that I
suspect if you keep on playing lags
you're not going to to get the wind you
all right but I guess game girl shot and
okay we get it he's good all right
everybody calm down
he just humiliated me I understand let's
do it again all right we'll see how you
fare with black we'll see how you okay
so maybe maybe the whole night gambit
thing to get a check isn't the best
thing huh yeah I don't know CLE also I
mean Syrian out not to get completely
this month on those black okay so we're
both we're both theory lists we're both
theory lists kittens actually we're just
wandering the wilderness okay so you're
going to give me I think I have to take
this check and and now I have to
anticipate it's not a big deal you know
one check is not a big deal okay
everyone take notes on everything Maxime
says one check is not a big deal he says
I'm gonna I'm all about playing checks
in a combination I agree with you I was
telling the view tzer's that they should
they should try to always think about
ways to get checks in succession like
back to back right yeah yeah nuts
of course and it was the most important
thing
okay so what are you gonna do where's
that night going next do you even have a
plan it's like you don't even have a
plan sometimes and sometimes I don't
need one that's the deal all right
all right he plays okay I got my second
check everybody should I go all-in
the problem is home and always my queen
okay I'm gonna guess that sacrificing my
queen would have been a bad idea so I'm
not here with you it seemed quite white
oh nice you this I have a threat yeah
you you do don't you miss a spot there
you go there you go all right now I'm
going to play the solid move not only
avoiding checks Maxine but improving my
position yeah it's also fine
so where did you think you had your
chances against Socorro and that
Armageddon game or in the in the blitz
playoff maybe game three we think uh
yeah games free I was little bit better
yeah you were better so I had I mean I
made one big mistake Benina quizzes that
made all my play you know yeah senseless
but otherwise I would have had some
chances to to win this game and I mean I
was more than one minute on the clock
and so on so I did have some chances
yeah I thought so too that that was a
critical game okay
I'm working toward my checks everybody
I'm trying to distract him by asking him
important chess questions look at that
he can't take the bishop he loses on the
spot yeah I can get my second check if I
wish but why be impatient oh I'm gonna
get some checks of my own you're gonna
get some checks of your own well you
know look you got one check NBD oh I
can't play king of one well you can't be
done okay I didn't see that uh-oh here
we go should I have to I have to bring
the bishop back I don't want to bring
the bishop back yeah but sometimes you
know what you want to do and what you
have to do yeah I know very different
things
it is very different I'm gonna I'm gonna
wreck a rough-cut raka Roka all right I
gotta go in for this check I gotta go in
for this check and just see if I can go
kamikaze with the Queen I've got you on
the edge no tent not yet
uh-oh oh no you're threatening a real
threatening real chess moves ah yeah and
all that was scary that you just did
that I'm avoiding you avoiding you like
the plague I got an idea
boys Oh No ah here he comes here he
comes with the checks on oh how did I
blow that
ah I was so distracted by you know
you're asking